[Music]
the Church of What's Happening Now baby
Sunday
edition it's the Catholics today SE he's
a pseudo Catholic and [__] what's going
on baby I'm Jewish that's basically
Catholic no it's not what's the
difference you don't have the 12
stations of across we have Passover no
it's not the same I right tell this
[__] guy they they started it they
started it they started the 12 stations
of across it's basically you and [__]
that's how you know when you're Catholic
when you I told my wife my wife like
well I don't understand I go listen when
you go to church and you look at the 12
Stations of the Cross if you're [__]
moved you're a Catholic if it brings a
teer to your eye you're a Catholic if
not it ain't going to work out for you
go across the street hang out with the
Protestants or whatever they're cracking
whatever they're doing or the Jews
whatever you want to do that's the thing
my wife didn't even know what the 12
Stations of the Cross are when you go to
a really powerful church and you look at
Jesus up there and then you look around
and you see the it's way when pontious
pilot come gets them then he punches
them they they break down the beaten
into 12 rounds don't they something and
they show them get handed that's the 12
stations of across for you non [__]
Catholics out there my main man in the
house today Big John McCarthy what is up
brother what's up beautiful dude thank
you for having me man oh my God we've
been dying to have you how'd you get the
weekend off from Brazil you know what I
just got lucky everyone thinks it's like
oh man how come we not how come we don't
go down because it's a long freaking
flight and you're on that plane and then
you got to come right back and it's like
everyone thinks you're on vacation there
it's like no you get to go to a airport
fly on the plane to Brazil go to a hotel
get to an arena go from the arena back
to the airport get on the plane go back
what's the travel time from LA to Brazil
about 14 hours That's Heavy D oh is long
Plus getting through customs that's only
the time in the in the air oh yeah and
what's the breakdown there's two flights
or just two flights usually yeah usually
either go to Miami or to Houston okay
that's and uh so you from there down to
Rio or South Paulo depending on find
where you're going going but it's you
know after being on a FL it's usually
like 4 hours to you know Houston or
Miami is that 4our part and then you get
your a little bit in between and then
about a 10 hour down to you know Brazil
long flight you get up and walk I I
don't fly internationally I just don't I
I don't think I'd have the patience I
started making it on the trip to New
York I'm back like I'm really good
because you bring the iPod you bring the
the computer you bring a book you bring
a pencil you bring a piece of paper
hopefully they have a movie but that 14
hour stuff I don't know how people do it
sitting there I've only done it once to
Israel and it was only like 12 hours 11
hours it's tough especially like an
international flight when odors start
popping up and [__] that's what will
kill me some [__] brings hummus
on the flight somebody takes their shoes
off you're on that [__] 10 hours
and you feel like going to the person
with the shoes off and going dog you got
to put those [__] dogs back on isn't
that what uh isn't that what John Candy
tell Steve Martin on Planes Trains and
Automobiles and he take takes his shoes
off and he goes woo my dogs are on
fire and then if you're sitting in coach
like I was sitting in coach I didn't sit
first class it's the same thing it sucks
everywhere no that's where you're at man
you know look at First Class business
class it's all right you can you get all
the movies and stuff you can stretch out
you're always in coach you're always in
coach and you're a big dude it's not
like you're it sucks it's horrible you
know especially at least United has got
economy plus so you know it gives you
that little extra bit so my knees aren't
getting crushed by somebody most of the
time but coach is horrible but they give
you the uh economy plus but then they
put handles on it oh yeah so if you're
sitting there by yourself I got to sit
like a [__] kid in a baby seat take
the handles off so you gave me the six
EXT extra inches United's great United's
got a good deal United will give you
extra leg room package mixed with the
Security package for 60 bucks so you
could pack you could get a first class
security to go through first class
instead of going through coach so they
they combine it it's like 60 9 bucks for
the first class and the the extra leg
room it's not bad cuz that's the whole
thing about flying is waiting in the
line that's the whole thing about flying
it's not anything else that bothers me I
already have it in my head I'm on a
flight I'm doomed for people who fly
once or twice a year like like I do it's
not that big of a deal for but for you
guys if you're flying once or twice a
week that's hours a week that you're
losing I could do it every weekend and
it's weird when I have to do it and not
pick up a check that blows for me like
if I have to do something on a personal
level like go to New Jersey just to see
family that blows that's unimaginable to
me getting on a plane not getting a
paycheck it's unimaginable to me so when
people go come and visit [__] you I got
to do comedy there if not it doesn't pan
out for me because I can't just sit on
that plane and just for no reason
vacations I don't have V vacations when
I stay here and go to Santa Barbara and
go to that place that has a lasagna with
the meatball in the middle have you gone
there Mrs McCarthy [__] tremendous
you understand I like taking a pict dude
give me my phone real quick I take
pictures of the people that I end up
having to sit next to in coach on these
long flights and some of them are
classic man here I got to show you one
that's hysterical dude that's what
Sebastian does my friend Sebastian goes
through the airports and take pictures
of people and they have their feet up
with no socks on and slippers and he
goes aren't you embarrassed he puts
little captions on them I would be I
don't know how to [__] people do it no
the victims and coach and all the way in
the back like an Expedia when you got in
the back like you got a good price but
they put you in the back with people
with handcuffs on oh yeah I love those
or they sit or they stick here right
next to the toilet oh God that's
horrible yeah you're just next to the
toilet for only like 10 hours it's just
it's you know one of the most amazing
things it's they just put me next to a
toilet but the whole row was empty so I
sacrifi that's not bad I had the whole
Row's empty I might even sit next to the
toilet for a while yeah it's not bad cuz
I can't sit inside no more I get too
much anxiety especially up in the air my
nose clogs up oh really so I can't
breathe so so if I'm sitting inside I
start panicking I get panic attacks so I
got to S on the outside so last time I
flew they had me somewhere they had me
in a good seat but inside and I go don't
you have anything outside she goes we
have the last row in the plane all to
you I go [__] it book it [__] I sat
there all the way from Miami in the back
like a doctor listening to music
scratching my [__] feet and
everything did you find did you find
this smoking Joe I'm I'm see I'm seeing
my granddaughter I'm getting nothing in
pictures of the ugly
people it's uh I've just listen flying
blows it does flying really sucks for
the American Consumer the person who
doesn't know flying is [__] shocking
because flying used to be something that
was fun you look forward to it you you
got you know when I was a kid I used to
fly out here from Jersey my mom would
put me on a Plane by myself to come out
here when I was 8 nine and 10 to see my
uncle by myself to Miami too [__] it and
that's even if you didn't get a first
class ticket if you fol by yourself they
put you in first first class cuz you
were kiding they give you wings and a
[__] captain's hat and first class
had perfumes in the bathroom and creams
it's not like that no more it's an ad
there was a time when on a plane there
was a [__] piano right yeah and you
could play the [__] piano on the
plane people would play the piano
upstairs remember if you watch Midnight
Express it's a two- floored [__]
plane they don't have those no more all
the planes used to be two floors so
upstairs was like a little first class
with a guy playing a piano with a pig
eating an apple I swear to [__] God I
swear to God nobody remembers that [__]
watch Midnight Express he takes him
upstairs no we've been on a two yeah on
a two se but there's no point there's no
more no more of that [__] now Big John
what did you start first refereeing or
being a police officer oh as a police
officer I became a police officer back
in uh 1985 how old were you I was 22 and
what made you well you come from a
family of cops what yeah my dad was a
police officer on La and it was funny
because I was bouncing I was doing a lot
of bouncing and uh I was uh just at the
time you think you're invincible and you
do all kinds of stupid stuff and uh I
was getting in trouble and my dad looked
at me he goes he says you better figure
out what in the hell you're going to do
in life because you're going to do one
of two things you're going to end up
being a cop where you're putting people
in jail or you're going to end up being
in jail so figure out which one's better
for you and I looked at him like you're
an idiot you don't know what you're
talking about you know he knew so you
know I met my uh my wife wife of 30
years back then and ended up figuring
you know I need to get a job where I can
freaking pay for things and stuff and so
I started trying to be a police officer
and I ended up working out I got on LAPD
that was where my dad was at he had just
uh retired and I was on it for 23 years
and were you lieutenant at the end hell
no man I was the the best my favorite
line that I would tell everybody is you
know they would all sit there and say
you know you need to promote you need
promote you need to do this I said you
know the best part about me and whoever
was the boss time best part about me and
Daryl Gates is we both have reached the
tops of our careers or it was you know
Willie Williams or Bernard Parks any of
them both reach the Pinnacles of our
careers I ain't going no higher I I
really did not want to I did not want to
be a supervisor I didn't want to I
didn't want to write paper on people I
wanted to take care of you know people I
I loved going out and taking care of
citizens and doing things for people
that the real thing there's all kinds of
police officers and you know there's
good ones and there's bad ones just like
there isn't any you know occupation
there is there's good Comedians and
there's shitty ones and I've sat through
some shitty ones you know and you go who
told this guy he's good at this and you
know there's there's ones that they're
afraid of being a police officer no
matter what they want to say they're
afraid of it they're afraid of the
people out there they're afraid of
dealing with people and so they do
everything they can to do the easy
things they pull over you know l they'll
pull over you know old people they'll
pull over the guy that they see coming
out of a business in a business suit and
write a stupid ticket or something like
that and I looked at that that's chicken
[__] you know I I I I swear to you I
wrote about five tickets in my career
and they were all to gang members and it
was I I if I stopped someone I would
stop you to put you in jail I would if I
thought that I you know you're doing
something bad but if you were you know I
don't I didn't care if you're doing 80
miles an hour in a 50 i' tell you hey
you need to slow down you know be safe
have a nice day boom and I would never
ride a ticket because why am I going to
ruin that guy's day or that girl's day
why am I going to make their insurance
go up and you know what I don't care if
the city made money I care that people
are having a safe day no one's bothering
them and I I enjoyed going out and
putting people in jail that cause
problems for other people in a bad way I
enjoyed putting gang members in jail had
no problem doing that I enjoyed uh if
someone was terrorizing an area in a
certain way or something I like trying
to find them and put them them away so
the neighborhood was better how much of
it is uh I don't know how they interact
with you like if if I've had I had a
friend in high school Who Loved arguing
with cops about he would speed and he
would get pulled over and he loved it he
loved arguing with them and he would get
tickets and and he would get in fights
with them and I've I've been pulled over
like think three or four times I've
never I got one ticket but other than
that I'm always very nice and they
usually seem to let you go well you know
and and this it's exactly what you're
saying if you're going to sit there and
you know I don't care who you are if I
pull you over and you sit there and you
say I said hey you let me see your
driver's license registration please you
know what's your name blah blah blah
I'll be nice I'm going to be as
respectful as I can to you I'm going to
treat you the way I would want to be
treated and if you start in with why did
you pull me over well the reason I
pulled you over is you know you're going
we'll say 65 and a 45 no I wasn't I was
not speeding well now you're saying I'm
a liar okay I don't lie I don't have to
sit I don't want to I don't do things to
people people that don't deserve it I
don't want to I'm not going to ruin your
day for no reason but don't make it to
where the you're making the police
officer say okay I'll prove it to you
and they're going to write you the
ticket because if you're asking for it
fine the best thing you can do anytime
you get stopped by a police officer is
say how you doing sir you know what I
don't know how fast I was going I was I
apologize here's where I was going I did
not realize I will slow down you know
take your time do what you're going to
do you and they're going to run you
because they're going to see if you have
any felony warrants or things like that
but most of them will come back and a
lot of times they're going to come back
and say hey have a nice day slow down
and what did it cost you it cost you a
little bit of time but if you want to
sit there and challenge them you're just
proving that you know what you are not
treating them the way they're trying to
treat you if you you know to get respect
you have to give respect and that's you
know that's the essence of life I I
drove without a license not because I
got DUI and nothing I had a Colorado
license and right before 9/11 I lost it
the license got lost on the plane and I
just didn't want to go get a license I
just [__] didn't want to go get a
license man it's a [__] pain in the
ass it is so from 2 to probably 2012 I
drove without a physical
license and I would get pulled over all
the time and never get a ticket because
I'd addressed the officer with respect
and tell him the truth and he One Cop
told me on the five he goes listen man
you were doing 70 or 80 whatever but you
know you were a gentleman I'm going to
let you go and you didn't have alcohol
in your bread that's why I don't believe
in drinking boob I do comedy I do not
drinking I can't handle myself when
there's a cop behind me even if I don't
have a gun in the car if I have nothing
in the car nothing drinking nothing I'm
still [__] like why is he behind me
last night I had a guy behind me for
three [__] miles before I got on the
710 but all those times I've never you
know I got to rest of the 37 times right
37 times you've been arest I was on I
was on a row for a while I never heard
that number oh I was on a roll for a
while from 84 to
85 and like a half I got arrested but
let go CU they couldn't get the proof
you know like I possession of stolen
prop uh tools they let me go possession
of stolen property they let me go I
always knew a cop or or something it was
always something going on and as all
those arrests I only have problems with
one police off tell how good I was one
time I got AR wrestle in
Jersey in Anglewood Cliffs and I had a
warrant in Newark and they arrested me
like at 2: in the afternoon and I hadn't
eaten lunch so I was 9:00 and they were
transfering me to Newark and I made the
cop I I talk to him nicely I go office I
haven't [__] eaten since breakfast
I'm dizzy you got to stop somewhere he's
I can't do it I go officer you telling
you they're not gonna [__] feed me
all night you can't do this to me where
would you presume we sto I go chance
dragging in he goes not in a million
[__] years you know why because I was
doing a steak out there one night for a
burglar and we could hear the rats the
cop wouldn't [__] pull over he goes
that place is [__] filthy finally he
pulled over he went in ordered it for me
got it out he let me eat it in the
backseat of the car pork fried rice and
an egg Groll that's how much respect I
had for cops and after a while you just
tell them the truth the cop that broke
my balls was in Colorado he was one of
those cops that was Johnny American he
would always say things to me like
little things to me in court and I would
break his balls cuz at that point that's
what it had become he was a [__]
scumbag to me but uh I've never had a
problem with a cop never in never I I
have I just don't understand how people
want to argue with a cop that's the last
[__] I want to argue with I just
want to leave the people who I've seen
do it I grew up in a very rich town it
was the it's people who are I'm not
saying everybody but the people I've
seen do it they they like the they like
having the power cuz like they they're
not worried about going to jail cuz they
have bail money and I don't know maybe
maybe maybe that's just them but the the
two or three people I've met who like
doing it were very rich when I was 18
for about a two-month period I
considered being a cop in the uh in the
early 80s there was a big a big hiring
in the early 80s in the east coast in
Miami there was a big hiring for
minority police officers and they went
after and if if you remember in Miami
they had the river cops oh yeah the four
cops that were [__] throwing people
in the ocean pulling them over taking
their drugs and killing them and [__]
drugs and money money because they
couldn't do enough background checks
fast enough they they didn't look at
juvenile records They didn't know that
these [__] kids were were crazy but
the same thing happened in my hometown
where a handful of kids that were crazy
got became cops the same thing out here
that's what happened that was rapael
Perez and all them and you know the
rampart Scandal and everything why do
you think LAPD gets such a bad rap my
girlfriend grew up out here and she she
said that the sheriffs are pretty cool
and she grew up in Englewood where like
there's a lot of like the police I used
to go drop her off and there were drug
dealers who were just always out it was
like a store and the police station was
a few blocks away and they just like
they they don't come around here for
that and and she she has she's she wants
to be a lawyer but she says LAPD has a
horrible reputation you know they have
recently really gotten there's all kinds
of stuff that goes into everything and
you know they try to get so politically
corre correct that you lose your
Effectiveness in what you're doing and
when again this is the whole point when
the citizens know that W the police
aren't even going to come around here
well that's the citizens are also the
idiot selling the narcotics at times and
they're the ones that you know are
bringing the people that are buying the
narcotics and the way the people buy the
narcotics is to break into the home and
steal that person's you know TV or
computer and go out and sell it and to
get the money for their stuff and and so
it's just it's a vicious cycle that is
going on and you have got to have people
knowing you're going to be there to
cause them a problem because if you're
there to cause them a problem they're
going to try to go somewhere else
they're going to try to do it another
way they're not going to try to stop but
they're going to get out of that one
area and then you know move on you find
where they're going and start to cause
them a problem again and that's what
police work is about police work is is
not about you know going out and
stopping just any body on the street
it's about being smart watching going up
doing what we call Ops and observations
watching the people watching what
they're doing if I if I go and I stop
someone on the street for we'll say you
know I'm stopping because I think
they're a Narcotics seller trust me I've
been watching them I know where it's at
I'm not an idiot I'm not going to sit
there and just stop him for you know
nothing so I can't put him away I'm G to
sit there and either have information
from someone that has told me exactly
where they put it at or I've watched
them seen where they put it at and so
you know I've had it where you know guys
will take there's grass and they'll
they'll they'll pull up the grass and
they'll be three feet underneath the
grass and so as as you're there you
would never know unless you went and
watched them you watching and you sit
there and all you got to do is watch
them for a while watch them to a cell
boom go in there pop that's not mine
you're right it's not yours yes it is I
watched you go there too bad so now it
is my word against yours my whole thing
is I don't lie there's no reason to lie
if you if you tell the truth it never
changes when you tell a lie you need to
then start telling more lies to try to
cover that lie so tell the truth if you
can't if you can't catch the person that
day then you don't catch him that day
you said something very interesting in
the beginning that I was going to talk
to you about and you brought it up I
think that and I don't think it's just
La I think I travel and you travel it's
the [__] country as a whole uh I
think the social uh shortness has even
caught up to police officers when you go
in and you see a cop and you pull over
you see a cop and you asking for
directions they look at you like you're
from another planet now you can't talk
to an that like cop you ever say like
good afternoon to Cops and they're
eating lunch at Boston Market they look
at you like why is he talking to us why
I can't [__] say hello to four
[__] cops I'm trying to give you the
respect you deserve you're outside you
know most people look at you like you
you're this for the community it's like
my friend says my friend's a detective
in Jersey because they all come crying
for Papa when they get bit slapped but
when I drive down the street and they're
having a good time they give me the
finger and [__] when they get bits
slapped they're all crying for [__]
Papa uh they have forgotten what I grew
up with cops with B cops in New York
City where you got to know them and they
got to talk to you and they got to walk
home with you that's the difference
though see back you know in when I came
on you know the guys that I was I was
learning from were guys that had 20
years on the department they've been
there they've done all these different
things guys walking beats in New York
the one thing about New York New York is
when you look at the area it's small but
the amount of people in it is huge and
the amount of you know officers they
have is huge too but those officers are
responsible for a very small area but
they get to know everybody they get to
know everybody they know what
everybody's doing they know the guys
that are doing the stupid stuff and
they'll sometimes sit there and say hey
get out of here but they don't they're
not going to take their whole thing is
to make sure that everyone is just kind
of flowing together and Society is
working and those guys can tell you
things based on experience that what has
happened recently as we get into this
you know you know I don't want to
say it's not an affirmative action but
it's an almost an affirmative action on
everyone it's it's like AYSO soccer oh
everyone should get to play that's
[__] okay it's not everyone gets to
play it's you know the best people
should go forward but there needs to be
time in that so what we have is we get a
bunch of I used to you know teach for
the department near the end of my career
and I'd get a class of 50 people and out
of that 50 people I would have 35 that
had some type of degree BS ba Master's
MBA or PhD becoming a police officer and
I'd have about 15 that were
military or didn't have any kind of real
experience high school education but you
know got got in and the people that had
the the
degrees the problem with them was is we
have done things and we have made it to
where everyone is oh it's okay we're
going to help you out we're going to do
things for you we're going to everyone
should get a chance to play
and when I grew up when you grew up I
would go outside at 7 o'clock in the
morning after feeding myself because you
know no one was there to make me you
know breakfast I fed myself and on the
weekends and I would go out and I get on
you know a bike if I had that or a
skateboard and I'd go to my friend's
house and I just knew that I had to be
home at six o'clock at night for dinner
and if I wasn't home I was gonna get my
ass beat but I would go out and I'd go
with my friend Vince or my friend Ken
and we'd go out and we would make
decisions all day long most of them
really bad most of them are really
screwed up but we would make those
decisions and then we would have
consequences based upon the decisions
that we made and we learned how to make
a decision but the problem with kids now
is even my kids growing up you know my
wife would sit there and you know Ron
wanted to play with Bobby so my wife
would call Bobby's mom Ron wants to play
with oh yeah Bobby wants to play with
Ron well we'll bring Ron over and he'll
be over there in a half hour great we
take Ron and we drop him over at Bobby's
house and Bobby's mommy's there to make
sure that everything's going right and
if they're going to go someplace Bobby's
mom's going to go with them and they
don't have to make a decision at all
because it's all being done for them
they don't make any decisions and so
they don't know how and so then we get
all these people that are all educated
who come into an academy me and I put
him in a hard situation I'll put him in
thing make a decision now go and and
they want you to give them the answer
and they can't do it and they are then
they'll make it through the Academy I
try to get rid of them they'll make it
through the academy and they're great
test takers so then they'll Elevate
themselves without knowing how to do the
job because they don't really do the job
they just take test and with those tests
after two years they're a sergeant after
five years they're a lieutenant and they
don't know how to grab their ass with
either hand and that's the problem with
most departments today you get all these
people they're very educated but they
don't know how to do police work like
the old people did do you think that's
not naming any incidents but anytime
there is an incident do you think that's
a main part of the problem absolutely
it's a big part of the problem AB the
[__] L absolutely absolutely look
there's all kinds of ways to do police
work here here's the here's the thing
you can look at you know I'm not and I
don't know exactly what happened we'll
say you you got the Michael Brown
incident people can sit there and say
what they want Michael Brown attacks a
police officer he goes inside of the car
he gets shot inside the car his thumb
comes off and he steps back and this is
Witnesses and this is all in if you look
at the true records of it and he decides
to attack the officer again and the
officer shoots now I'm telling you would
I have shot him no I wouldn't have but
here's the difference I have certain
rules that I lived by I would shoot at
what I know not at what I think that's a
weird statement but that's the truth if
I know that he is a deadly threat to me
he has a weapon that can take my life
I'm going to shoot you I'm going to drop
you I'm going to end your ability to
hurt me I'm not trying to kill you I'm
trying to stop you most police officers
live on the the premise that people will
respect the badge they'll respect the
power of the badge that oh it can take
their freedom away and put them in jail
and it will a lot of the time but people
expect police officers to be these
they're all educated in the law they're
psychologists they'll handle all of your
personal you know domestic dispute
problems they can all fight [__]
they can't most of them can't do
anything so when I look at someone you
know as simple as it is you'll see
police officers coming up on cars and
they'll walk up on a car I will tell you
anytime a police officer walks up on the
car the person that's in the car has
them I'll kill the police officer every
time I I can show you how I used to
teach it I used to do it there's no way
for the officer to win if the person
really wants to get go after him now
most people are good people they're not
going to go after the officer the
officer relies on that fact the second
part is officers don't want to get into
physical
altercations why well because there's a
gun involved no matter if it's the
person who's got one he's got one so
they don't want to get in you know te up
their uniform they might not be able to
fight real well so they're afraid of
getting in that physical altercation so
they'll keep people people in a car
where they don't know anything about
what's inside the car which is the real
danger instead of pulling them out of
the car putting them up here and so now
the person they want to be want to
attack the officer physically they can
okay attack me go ahead that's my job to
be professional and learn how to be
better at doing certain things than you
and if you're not doing those things as
a police officer then you're not being
smart about being professional there's
life insurance policies for everything
learning how to do Brazilian jiu-jitsu
or fight or know how to actually handle
yourself if you have to for a police
officer it's a life insurance policy
that's what you're talking about so when
you're not doing it you're saying you're
lazy and a lot of people are
lazy uh now for me growing up that
neighborhood cop became my uncle he was
also a deterrent he also by right of the
neighborhood if you acted up he'd
[__] kick you in the ass and take it
to your house and knock on the door and
say excuse me your son disrespected me
and I gave him a kick in the [__] ass
and then your mom would give you a bat a
bit slap in front of the cop and it was
understood and your mom on the way out
would go by the way he ever disrespects
you knock him the [__] out now you had a
green light now you know if you played
hookie this guy you know we had and and
it's funny because I was blessed I have
been blessed with the best police
officers ever around me as a kid we had
a guy looked like AAR from f Chucky mcre
he calls in his uncle and we would he
was an all State basketball player so no
matter if he was a cop or not he was
still a basketball player so we played
basketball we 13 and he pull up we go
what you want to play hoops and he go I
don't have time we did that to him till
one day he goes you little [__]
he took the belt off he put it in the
trunk of his car he took his police
shirt off and played Hoops we would make
him play Hoops then then we'd abuse him
don't come here no more with colored
socks cuz he would wear colored socks
you're going to cut yourself you're
going to poison then we all go to murder
we would torment him we had another cop
a kid that we were friends with and we
became friends with his father his
father was a No Nonsense guy his father
would [__] backhander his father
would backhand the son at school with
his arms folded he would just go and the
son would drop then he picked him up
again and one night he called us dining
and dashing they sent him the Chinese
guys were waiting for us to kick the
door down we we ate and we're ready to
run and they locked the door on us so
we're like the cops are on their way
when we see Mr vanich we're like [__] he
came in he pulled us all together he
goes I'm not gonna take you little
[__] to jail give me all your
money like we got no money he goes okay
I'm gonna pay the $40 tab for you guys
but at one o'clock tomorrow if I don't
have this $40 I'm putting a personal
warrant on you he goes I'm gonna knock
the [__] out of all four years at 12:00
we were there with his $40 that's good
they meant something different to us
they were somebody else to us I don't
see that anymore they have a taekwan do
school on Hollywood Boulevard it's run
by cops is that still run by the cops
there I don't know on Kena yeah it's a
little place with a bad it's like a PA I
grew up at pal yeah when I came from
Cuba I was a pal guy in the corner they
would take you to the police station and
make you shoot a 32 or 22 and then give
you the bullet to take home yeah they
give you the [__] Target they teach
you how to shoot pool they took me to
Detroit you know I'm a pal guy so I I
got it growing up I really got it well
you said when you when you earlier you
said that some a lot of cops who trained
you had 20 years experience yep is there
a lot more turnover now people stay for
like 5 years oh yeah yeah absolutely
yeah you get a lot of people that it's
not it is not the same thing and you you
just the other part is it used to be you
know back a long time ago working Patrol
there was there was a certain amount of
honor to it that you were the guy out
there actually doing the job you were
you were dealing with the public you
were and then it got to the point where
your supervisors were saying why why are
you still working Patrol why why are you
working Patrol what are you doing why
don't you why don't you work the
specializ why don't you go do this why
don't you be a detective why don't you
be a sergeant and they made it to where
if you're the the officer that just
stays in Patrol well obviously you're
you're you know not that smart and they
they put it they tainted it and it they
made it to where the people that are
really good are always trying to go
other places because that's what
everyone is expecting Patrol is a great
place to be now it can get old for
anyone but it when you start having
twoyear Police Officers Training zeroy
year police officers you know your
Department's got problems you did the 20
years I did 23 and what's the I know you
would know this but what's the average
now people do five years and they're
like I don't want to be a cop no more
well I mean you get a lot of turnover
you but you get a lot of guys going all
the way you know my my sister's been a
police officer now and she's got like 31
years on she's on LA County Sheriff's
she's a lieutenant there she's been
there forever you know and you know it's
been a great job for her she's done you
know a lot she does commercial crimes
now she's super smart she knows what
she's doing what's commercial crimes
commercial crimes is like you know um
you get people that go in and they're
embezzling money from a business or
they're you know people are coming in
and they're you know doing things that
they shouldn't do taking money that
shouldn't be taken and finally the owner
and I I've been one of those owners you
know realizes I'm being ripped off and
then they go and get all the paperwork
and start doing all the background to
get here's how the person's been
stealing this is how long they've been
doing it this is where the money's come
from this is how much the total is and
sometimes they go after the person
sometimes they don't you know unlike a
lot of felons and a lot of people in
society right now I've never ever ever
had any ha prehension towards police
officers uh I've seen good cops and bad
cops you know my mother had a barn in
Union City a cop would come in every
week for an envelope his name was Gino
coming with his little outfit on my mom
would give him an envelope and a drink
if something happened he was always the
first cop on the scene if your window
broke he went there and sat outside so
nobody broke into your business you know
and I never had a problem with I seen
other cops that came in and broke my
mother's balls at the bar and that dude
ended up shot the Cubans [__] shot
him in 76 they just had something in the
local my local high school paper about
his son's older now and whatever I seen
him from I've never ever had you know
even the Michael Brown thing the kitten
Staten Island I've always said that
unless you know the [__] job shut
your [__] mouth unless you know what
it is to F the other night we almost got
caught in something my oh [__] and I was
petrified because that's how it goes
down we saw the kid running we were me
and him were get in our car and we saw
the kid running and we saw the police
back up and put the light on us he
followed us we're like oh no I I just
thought this guy was running I thought
he was going to catch a bus or something
and you're like oh the cops are
following him and we pulled into the
alley to leave and the cops went by with
a little light I was like oh [__] oh
[__] and then they got got behind this
did they really yeah they got right
behind you didn't know it I I drove I
was like they're going to pull us over
I'm have to put my hands out because
they're going to think the per in the
[__] car maybe he kidnapped us he
ain't going to kidnap me but I saw him
running and [__] I uh I I've never and
I've never seen the outcry that's lately
in all my years of being in this country
it's everybody feels entitled it's like
well you know you shouldn't you know no
one should be stopping me you I haven't
done anything and it's like we do things
all the time I can tell you there's so
many things you know it was funny
because people say you can't stop me I
didn't do anything it's like here let me
make this very clear for you between
state laws La municipality codes all
these things trust me they can stop you
for just about anything I mean you there
there's codes where you can't wash your
car in the street or something you know
it's ridiculous there's so many
different things so if the officer wants
to stop you yeah he can stop you you
know it's what he does with it and the
way he treats you that tells you who he
is as a person and everything but you
know I just watched you know Dave Herman
is you know you know an MMA fighter I
like Dave he's a good guy and I see you
know he got stopped he ends up driving
you know multiple miles with the police
behind
him
officer if they are going to pull you
over why are they pulling you over well
they only know what they are going to
pull you over for they know oh this
person's tail light is out that's the
reason I'm pulling them over but that
person in the car could have just done a
Rob
could have gone and done something and
so in their mind the officer knows they
know they know I just committed the
robbery and that's why they're pulling
me over and so this is where you get
that the trust Factor police officers
are leery of people because they don't
know everything that's occurred and they
know why that the reason they're going
to do something but they have to be
careful with everybody that they do
something with because if you don't take
those precautionary steps you can run
into that one person that is the person
that just robbed a store is doing
something that you didn't you're not
stopping them for and now they have the
upper hand on you so you they have to go
through certain steps to protect
themselves and make sure that
everything's right but if someone as
long as someone complies if a police
officer says put your hands up put your
freaking hands up them big deal I'm not
putting them up I'm calling my attorney
[__] what the [__] is wrong with you
you know and it goes both ways you know
I've seen it you know you know police op
tells you get down on your knees get get
it down on your face there's a reason
why they're doing it it's and if it's
not you you got nothing to worry about
now the police officers need to have
some common sense too cuz I can tell you
I've seen it too many times you know the
police officer will run a car and the
car will come back stolen it comes you
as it comes up on the computer it's
going to say this is a code 37 vehicle
stolen blah BL tell you the place and
stuff and as the police officer you got
to have enough Common Sense what do I
see driving the car you know if I see a
a male between 16 and 50 years old guess
what you're getting pulled out you're
getting put on your face that's just the
way it's going to be but when you see
you know an elderly couple you know
that's 70 years old in their Sunday Best
going to church it's telling you someone
didn't they got their car back someone
didn't pull it out of the system don't
take that lady and put her on her face
in the street have some common sense you
know and that common sense is what will
lead people to not having a problem with
some of the things police officers do
you got to have common sense I remember
like in the the early 80s I've never
ever trust me I'm telling you this I
don't like drinking and dry just
something about it just something about
it that it's like stealing a car [__]
if you get caught stealing a car you're
a [__] [__] we've had this comat I
can't get out of it I'm in it I'm in the
[__] thing at least that's not my
wrench officer I didn't hit him with the
bat that was there I don't know what
happened he fell but if I'm in the
[__] car you got me right in checks I
never got that I never got so many
crimes but one time I was in a friend I
was in the car with a buddy of mine this
[__] idiot was crazy
I loved him in fact his brother just hit
me up on Facebook he was crazy but not
in a bad way and we were go it was
freezing out in Jersey and the cop was
doing [__] 10 miles an hour in front
of us and what if Fernie do passes him
on the right and the cop pulls Fernie
over he pulls F out and F's telling the
cop dog it's [__] too cold for this
you're going to write me a ticket but
before the whole thing went down I was
sitting next to F the cop's like license
registration I looked at the cop I'm
like officer arrest him he's been
drinking the [__] cop started
laughing his ass off so much he just
gave us a license to go home just take
him the [__] home you know like that's
how funny but I've had situations when
they're they don't respond to a funny
joke oh yeah and that's [__] crazy
cuz then your that's crazy that's when
and and like I came up when I got into
all those problems it was in Jersey I
got into problems when I was in Jersey
my mom had died I got crazy and there
was one time I was in Newark and all
those places that's where those cops
don't [__] around like that's where I
would hate to be a cop and I know this
cop this guy kept busting this cop's
balls he was he was bleeding from every
arist in his [__] body this guy
needed 100 stitches and they put him in
the cell this is the early 80s when
there was no paper they put really you
bleeding put you in the cell wait for
court let the judge Stitch your
[__] ass up and I remember
going in front of the judge and watching
him walk in with the chains and you
could see the drip of blood all the way
they wouldn't take this [__] to
get stitched up those are the things
that always scared me about like I never
got touched by a cop ever ever not even
in a bad way I always got my handcuffs
put on and they left me the [__] alone
look at Big John look at at me Big John
I used to be crazy man how what happens
my I had a buddy who used to work on
Cops I think he still does and in cops
the thing is they always you always see
them say tell me the truth and would
that actually help like let's say I had
drugs or something on me and I told you
the truth would it actually help or no
no okay just [__] yourself shut your
[__] mouth that's tell shut your
mouth just tell the cop the truth off I
can't talk I I remember one time we went
[__] bagging when I was like this was the
hot thing I don't give a [__] if
somebody gets mad you're not beating up
on [__] you're beating up on perverted
old men we were like 18 and we get a
good-looking guy and we put him out his
bait in fact the good-looking guy his
father was the chief of police all right
all right and his cousin I hung out with
his cousin and he was a mafia guy so
this is the house the the spectrum they
don't talk I think the chief of police's
sister the chief of police and his
sister that's how they were related was
was so uh he was the chief and the other
kid I hung out with was the gangster's
father so they didn't really talk but I
hung out with this guy and he was de
bait and one day we got pulled the cops
goddess the goddess is the guy was
getting beat up he was like a
50-year-old pervert or something like
that and they took us to the police
station but the one cop knew the One Cop
kept looking at us weird the one Gung
whole cop kept saying arresting you guys
for assault but this one [__] cop
older cop kept knowing and he walked
over to us later on he goes what really
happened out there tonight and I go
offic this guy was trying to suck our
dick you know that's what really
happened and we gave a bit slap and
stuff and the guy goes let me come right
back and he left for like three minutes
he came back and let us out of the S
he's like just don't come back and don't
go up there and smack those
[__] if you see them contact me
and I'll go up there because when I grew
up the city City and the park were
completely different so the sheriff's
department ran that Hudson County Park
and the sheriff's department they were
mean but they were by the book like one
night they pulled us over again we were
out there we had a mirror a Coke on top
of the car a mirror like a like the kid
pulled the mirror out of his bathroom
and we had that's when we used to snort
coke outside the early a big full length
mirror a big on the trunk of the car and
we just snot and blow on the trunk of
the [__] car I mean who does this cop
cop walks up there what are you doing
miror just looking at ourselves we broke
it when the cop pulled up we threw it on
the floor and it broke and he's like why
the [__] you guys got a mirror out here
I'm my buddy and he goes what's going on
him and there was an argument some guy
had an argument and the guy flagged down
the cop I never forget this cop coming
over and going excuse me he pulled the
kid over the kids like arrest him [__]
him and the the sheriff looks at me he
goes listen really really you're going
to do this to me at a quarter of [__]
12 on a Thursday night you're [__] he
goes you couldn't take him across the
street and beat him up like any local
any any anybody with common sense if you
hit him here I have to do common I have
to do paperwork do me a favor take them
across the street do what you want them
all right I mean that's and you
shouldn't do that as a cop but he was
they these were the guys that patroled
they knew the area they knew what was
going on they knew that we were going to
do something we weren't bad kids it
wasn't like we were [__] shooting
cops and like that it was one cop Phil
Sims he L just like Phil Sims I'll tell
you how got I'll tell you how cool Phil
Sims was one night my buddy called him
out and Phil Sims says I'll tell you
I'll come here tomorrow at 3:00 we fist
fight in front of Nick's Pizza they
showed up the next day uh Phil Sims was
like 28 my friend was like 19 they
fought like maybe two rounds they got up
shook hands and that was it there you go
he kept torturing Phil Sims Phil Sims
said [__] you he fought a cop yeah have
you ever seen that movie End of Watch
they did that in End of Watch it was a
pretty great movie no I didn't see no oh
was really good I didn't see nothing
like that it actually is a good movie I
I hate cop movies it it was a good one
it actually was pretty pretty pretty
accurate that was a the best thing about
that was when you get in a in a you get
in a Pursuit down in the South End
that's where that was at they were
supposedly out of Newton but you get
it's all alleys and things are flying up
in the air and you're busting butt
through it and that the first car scene
on when they had the chase right very
accurate it was great big John before we
move any further where were you when
they robbed that bank in 98 one of my
first week in La the North Hollywood
bank robbery I want to ask you that oh I
you know I was off that day in fact we
were were going up to um we were going
up to Big Bear with my family and I
someone said hey hit the TV there's
something going on and I saw it and I
wasn't part of that at all but I ended
up doing the full investigation because
I was one of the expert Witnesses for it
to talk about what the officers did and
how they did it and what what the
suspects are doing and why it was right
and what was right and wrong because
there was a lawsuit later on by the
family of Amil MOS Sereno he was the
second guy that died in it he was the
guy that was was mostly in the car for a
lot of it uh they sued the department
sued the city for you know wrongful
death because it was right for their
husband or father or whatever you want
to say to be out shooting at people when
did you retire I retired in 2007 so I
mean you were a police officer in this
city during some of the best [__]
news in this city you were a cop during
the OJ trial oh yeah 94 oh yeah you were
a cop when big you were a cop when
Biggie got shot oh yeah we were at The
Comedy
Store and uh what else up cuz I was
thinking about you were a cop during a
lot of during the riots during all
during the riots that's oh [__] 94
that's right 94 the riots 92
9392 April of 92 I just started comedy
and I was doing comedy at the Chinese
restaurant and the whole thing was on I
couldn't believe like California I never
[__] like California I'll never go to
[__] California look at that guy
hitting the head with the brick OJ start
with the OJ my God you know I was such a
fan of O growing up I was a fan of OJ
Simpson I loved OJ Simpson and uh I mean
everything about OJ Simpson I thought
was cool man that was the juice and I
was working in Hollywood I was working
Hollywood division I had just gotten uh
transferred from 77th Southwest Division
to I had to go to what we call a new uh
Bureau because there's four bureaus as
far as LAPD there's Central Bureau West
Bureau Valley Bureau and South Bureau
and when you're a young officer you go
to out of the academy they're going to
send you to a bureau and normally you're
there a year and I was able to be down
in South Bureau for almost two and they
have to transfer you out of the South
Bure so they put me to West Bureau which
was up in Hollywood so I you know it was
a good place to go to so I was working
up in Hollywood and I'm working morning
watch and there's an old crusty guy his
name was Jee Fone man big pitted face
and good guy but just kind of by the
book you know just a bit of a hard ass
and he calls for an extra unit down off
of Melrose and Martell and it's about
12:30 12:35 in the morning and I'm right
around the corner tell me I'll be right
there and I pull up and there's this
black Ferrari tester Roa and at the time
a Ferrari test Rosa was a cool car and
it's got a license PL it says juice and
I'm like God damn I get out and sure
enough I see there's this pretty blonde
and there's OJ Simpson and um like you
know come over towards Jean and he says
he goes hey he says I want you to stand
with him he says I'm going he says I got
to talk to her he said but just stand
and talk to him find out what he says
went on right I said all right said come
over here right how you doing and I said
you know what's going on and I'm I'm
talking to him and he's saying oh man he
I'm in the car you know and she's
getting mad at me and she's starting to
hit he goes I'm putting my hand up to
try you know keep her from hitting me
and stuff he goes he says you on my
forarm yeah he says I think I did hit
her in the forehead with my forarm as I
told her to stop he goes goes but you
know I'm just trying to keep her from
you know hitting me and he goes and then
we get pulled over and you know she
she's telling him you know that I hit
her in in the head and stuff and I'm
like all right you know I said look you
know come on you if you if you're
getting mad with you know your lady or
something like that D pull over get out
of the car Walk Don't You can't touch
her right so then Jean comes and he says
he goes I'm gonna take him to jail I
said Jean his OJ Simpson dude I'll just
take OJ Simpson to jail I said he goes
let me talk to him real quick he says
you you talk so then I talk
to his wife and you know go to go
through the whole thing and tell her
look you know you can't hitting each
other and said you both go to jail I
said this is stupid you need to act like
adults and you need to work things out
and you don't touch don't hit each other
just talk you know be adults about
things I said do you want him to go to
jail and she goes no I go well I don't
think he wants to go to jail either so
you guys need to work it out and you
need to we'll try to explain to the
other officer so in the end I get jean
to let him go and it's about 5 years
later he ended up cutting her head off
so I'm an idiot but there was an arrest
after that what's that there was an
arrest after that for the domestic
violence oh he had he had multiple
domestic violences after that domestic
violences yeah but it was a start and it
was you know look at I know it was
because I looked at that's OJ Simpson
I'm not going to screw of this career
I'm not going to make you know things
over something that you know no guy
should hit you know his wife should not
do it if you do it you're an idiot and
uh you need to grow up but at the time I
was young and I just looked at like I'm
not going to take OJ Simpson to jail
that's stupid so you know I did probably
the wrong thing now that you look at it
you know knowing what happened but it
happens you know you know everyone
thinks because people are known or they
you know you know they know them they
see them on TV that you know they live a
better life a different life everybody
you know people are people and people
have you know anger issues people have
egos people do stupid things it's just
part of you know everyday life and
police officers make me mistakes I made
a mistake that night I shouldn't have
talked Jean out of taken him he probably
should have because maybe it would have
you know changed things I don't think it
would have but if it hadn't been OJ do
you think you would have arrested
him no honestly don't not because it's
not like if she had
marks that's different that's saying hey
you're hitting her but neither one of
them had marks and so there was nothing
there there was an argument and look you
know what I have probably the greatest
marriage there is and my wife is as
great to me as anyone could be but
there's times where she can even get mad
at me and I can get mad at her and
that's just you know that's people so
you know hitting and stuff no words
happens all the time it's funny because
at that time the domestic violence thing
wasn't wasn't quite as big wasn't quite
as big so it was getting there if you if
you didn't have any visible marks people
argue people argue and sometimes people
get loud I say [__] you sometimes I slam
the door for a cop to come and arrest me
would be a [__] heartache you know
but that's what happens when you can't
control yourself what about uh the riots
how where the [__] were you and all that
[__] went down that's so you're you're
on the four 70 years maybe six years
yeah I was I was working on was called
westbo crash I was working gangs at the
time and um there a video YouTube yeah
old video of Me on YouTube it was um you
know the what happened with the Rodney
King thing and everything the uh
Lawrence pow was a guy that I worked
with and I worked around him and wasn't
my favorite and I even told supervisors
hey you need to set him straight you
know he's very he's very big when people
have handcuffs on I said you know take
the handcuffs off someone and see what
it is don't don't you know I told him
you know don't treat someone in a way
that you wouldn't if you weren't wearing
that batch so if you know if you're
going to walk up while you're wearing a
t-shirt and jeans to that person and say
that go ahead do it to you know the same
thing but if that's not the way you
would act then don't act that way as a
police officer so you know the whole
thing happened with Rodney King and then
they got off and you know I knew I knew
it was going to blow up there was not a
doubt in you know my mind there wasn't a
doubt in my partner's mind and we got uh
called in we were we were sent to
Hollywood to work that night and we got
called uh immediately to Wilshire they
do what's called we call it code Alpha
that's to meet up and we get I get to
Wilshire station I pull in this the uh
the parking lot of Wilshire station and
we're there for five minutes and all of
a sudden there's a there's a Shell
station that's right on the corner of
LaBrea and um Venice which is very close
to the Wilshire police station and you
hear gunshots going off there and I hear
officer comes out with a officer needs
help over uh the radio and we jump in
our cars to go out and the captain comes
over the radio and says no one leave the
station no one leave the station and it
was like [__] you and I went out the
gates of that station that and uh see
the cards coming down we get little
Pursuit there's actually a little
shooting that happens off of it and the
games were on and honestly you know for
the I was there for about 20 hours that
first day I had a blast all the rules
were off I had a great time I'm telling
you right now people were nuts there was
you know you really had two you had
people that were trying to take wasn't
what wasn't theirs they didn't care
about Rodney King they didn't care care
about the police officers they cared
about getting freebies they cared about
what can I what can I put in my you know
apartment or my house that didn't belong
to me yesterday and there was those
people and there was the people that
were trying to keep what was theirs and
my job was to help the people trying to
keep what was theirs and take care of
the people that uh were uh doing the bad
things and all we would do is man we
would grab hold and Crush people down
have a bus come and they throw them in
there would be we'd send one officer to
write a whole Report with however many
people it was and I stayed out on the
streets till they called me in probably
about 10:00 the next morning let me go
home and 6 o'clock and I was back at
work and for two days I had a blast it
was the greatest time I ever had as a
police officer after that it was boring
how long did that last those riots well
the riots you know like I said two days
it was really going I mean when I say it
was going it was I mean there was fires
all over they were burning you know all
the you know they would a store and burn
it you know liquor stores were huge for
them to go into uh any kind of Appliance
or electrical thing they were trying to
break into and pawn shops you know
always going after pawns because there
was Guns and Things and we
um we were just going after you know
people that were doing the bad things
for the most part you know they they
would go into 7-Elevens and raid the
7-Eleven and set it on fire but what was
really starting to happen is then the
fire you know La you know City fire is
then calling even LA County Fire and
then to S you know put off the fires
then they were shooting at the you know
the fire fighters and stuff and so the
firefighters couldn't get into the fires
and it was a lot going on for two days
after two days it it pretty well it
slowed down a lot would it have changed
if there was the as live as Internet as
it was for Michael Brown would have been
different yeah absolutely right that's
what I was just thinking the internet
was just brand new brand new then I
don't even think most people even had it
AOL was like you know You' got mail you
know and stuff but it's uh at the time
that it happened with everything it
would have been a different thing now
yeah especially you know and it's not
even it's not so much the inter it's
like it's this you know everywhere you
go now you know and this is what's funny
about police work and stuff everywhere
you go um you know people have a video
camera it's their phone you know and and
like I said it's like it's no different
than telling the truth you know treat
people right my son is an LA County
Sheriff okay now I told him don't be a
police officer he's stupid enough he
goes and does it and you know he enjoys
it but I tell him wear a camera I want
you to wear a camera on you I want you
every time you stop someone every time
turn that thing on why because if you're
not out there to screw people over it's
only going to protect you it's going to
show you when people say he did this no
I didn't here and it takes care of all
the complaints and it used to be years
ago all these the ACLU and all these
different you know attorneys for
defendants or whatever would say we want
police officers to wear cameras and a
lot of police off are like I'm not
wearing a camera and it's like why if
you got nothing to hide what does it
matter and so now a lot of departments
are putting cameras on police officers
and all of their complaints are being
thrown out because the officer goes and
gets someone to complain about them they
have the camera they put show exactly
what happened with that entire
interaction they go the person's lying
and now all of a sudden the association
of attorneys for defendants Now does not
want police officers wearing cameras
because it's costing them money because
they're not getting the lawsuits it's
like everything's about money you know
you everything when it comes to police
work is being smart treat people the way
that you would want to be treated if
someone needs to be thumped then that
means that they're asking to be thumped
thump them but when they're done trying
to hurt you stop thumping them you got
rules they don't that's just the way it
is you know and you got to live by that
you got to understand I have to I have
to play by a certain set of rules as
long as you understand that it's a great
job it's a it's you know something
that's very fulfilling at times and you
can do a lot of good or you can sit
there and be a dummy and go out there
and think that you know what you can
rule the world the way you want to rule
it you're going to end up pissing people
off and getting yourself fired or put in
jail do you think the amount of money
that officers make cuz no no one makes
you become a cops so you know what
you're going to into paywise when you
sign up that's what's so funny though
you get all these police officers and
they all want to be rich it's like dude
you knew what you were signing up for
when you freaking did it but do you
think if they offered more money which I
know is hard because taxes are already
high as high as they are yep but if they
were able to offer more money they might
be able
to hire not I don't want to say better
people but people they wouldn't have to
hire the people who are doing the bad
stuff I I would tell you this the the
real problem with police departments and
hiring is there's too many things that
have gone on with people's rights to
okay I'm I am you know I'm six foot I
was 6'4 I was
235 pounds when I was going through the
Academy I was 280 pounds the entire time
I was a police officer up to 300
whatever you know there's certain people
that they look at me and they don't even
want to do the things that they're
thinking because they go it's not worth
it I might not win but when you have a a
someone come out out and say I am 3' 7
in tall but I have the right to be a
police officer well okay yeah I guess
you do but you have certain limitations
but courts and everything is now saying
that this person at 3 foot7 can do
everything that the 6'4 person is well
they can in certain ways my wife was a
police officer I'm telling you she's
smarter than I am okay she had a lot
better attitude than I had but there was
that one to
2% there's no way in the world world she
could deal with the way I could deal
with it it's just you know and she knew
and I I tried to teach her when she was
going on being a police officer is about
being smart but you know I can tell you
you know when when they're in the
academy you know they're they're taking
her and they're putting her through all
this training and stuff and they're it's
almost like going through the military
they're going to break you down to try
to build you up and tell you that you
can do these things and it got to a
point you know at one point you know she
she still thinks I'm an [__] for it
but you know she was getting to that
point she thought that she could
actually do physically certain things to
people I said and I told come here choke
me out I'm going to sit here choke me
out come on they they told you you can
you can choke anyone out choke me out
and you know I sat there and and she got
mad at me but that was the point of you
need to understand the truth there are
certain things that you can't do you
know and to sit there and to say that
anybody can choke another person out
it's just not true okay that's just not
the way it is if someone really knows
how to do it well they have a chance
against someone that doesn't have skill
in how to either defend it or anything
yeah there's always that but there's
always somebody out there that can beat
you and if you think that everybody is
created equal they're not and you know
you need to be smart enough to realize
there are limitations in everything
there's limitations when it comes to
being a school teacher and what certain
people can do and what certain people
can't everyone can do the job of
teaching but is everybody the same no
and it's the same with being a police
officer and
departments are forced to hire people
that probably shouldn't be police
officers and then when they're going
through acmis and when they're failing
tests that are absolutely important to
Public Safety but that person has the
right to have an attorney go to court
and say no they shouldn't have been
fired because it's not the real world in
the academy and the real world is what's
going to take it so what you're saying
is you want to put this person out on
the street and let them do this in the
real world so then when they actually do
either shoot someone they shoot in a
shot or what's worse to me is they don't
shoot somebody who needs to be shot
because they are taking the life of
somebody else and that's what really
happens is then you allowed someone to
die to now say well maybe we shouldn't
have this person you can't do that but
that's what that's what occurs and
that's what's wrong with you know just
the way things are but as somebody who's
gone through through the system and it's
been the other way female police
officers offer a different thing they
offer a Comming
effect and if I see Mrs ma coming at me
my in that's because you're having
different thoughts you're thinking you
see Miss Mack coming at you going yeah
baby no no when I see Mrs ma coming at
me I have the natural uh woman thing mom
you know she's not going to mess with me
that's because you're a good guy yeah
but I I I got locked up and I never saw
being locked up doesn't mean you're a
bad guy no I understand that there
there's there's actually in in my
opinion there is about 2% of
society okay that they're bad people
they're bad okay that's 2% maybe I it
could be even less than that there's
there could be 45% that have gone to
jail that those 40 some per they're not
bad people they just made a mistake and
we all make mistakes but I just made a
felony mistake he got caught for it
there's plent people who haven't got
caught oh yeah but you're gonna get
caught you're always going to get caught
if you continue you're always going to
get caught you're always going to get
caught you got to be an idiot not to
think that's why they give you the
paroles and the long probation when
Chris Brown got the six-year probation I
knew that [__] [__] was going to get
in trouble again I knew it it doesn't
take a [__] genius but see you look
and you go why do you know because he
thinks he's above everybody he thinks
that he's different he's not different
he shits like everyone else he freaking
puts his pants legs on one you know one
at a time but he thinks he's different
and he should be able to be on a
different standard no you're a person
you're an idiot you hit a girl you hit a
pretty girl a girl that you should be
respecting and taking care of I don't
care if she got mad at you I don't care
if she pissed you off she could have
said that you're the you're a terrible
person doesn't mean that you should put
your hands on
her you're not better than anybody
that's just Beau the [__] thing no
it's uh being a cop is a hard job and
all the press that you see for a guy
like me that's been on the other side
and I'm telling you that being a cop
it's like I've seen cops get jumped on
I've seen I've [__] seen it I've seen
how quick something happens it happens
[__] quick Jack there's no hold on
there's no bow there's no let me grab
your GE and flip you there's nothing it
happens it just you know and you see it
have to react to it a certain way and uh
I have a lot of resp I have a lot of
respect for cops and teachers I think
that's the two hardest [__] jobs in
society you got to deal with people you
have to make calls on the dime and
you're always going to get criticized
about that call whether it's right or
wrong you know whether it's right or
wrong they want teachers to have guns
now really they want some teachers to
get because you got idiots coming into
schools that are arm trying to hurt you
know people that are innocent people
yeah I could see putting you know what
what I don't have a problem with you
know a a good teacher that has had an
established career that wants to be
armed to help with security if someone
comes into their school I don't have a
problem you know I hate to say everyone
gets onto this fix about guns and you
know I could take a gun right now and
put it in the middle of this table and
you know what no one's going to get shot
because the gun's not going to jump up
and shoot anybody it's only the idiot
controlling it to shoot somebody and you
know what you can sit there and you can
say well we're going to legislate and
we're going to take it away you can't
take them away they're out there you
know to sit there and think that
everyone has a registered weapon you're
an idiot you know anybody that wants to
get something they can get it it's just
you know it's out there so if you think
you're going to legislate you know those
away it's never going to happen they
will always have the ability to have
that gun to go in now no one does have
one it's about educating people it's
about having people that sit there and
you know a teacher that says I would I'd
rather be arm you know look I got
friends that are pilots you know there's
a you know Mark Smith who is a you
know MMA referee working in in Nevada
Works UFC events this we're talking a
guy here that was you know in the Air
Force he was on the Thunderbirds all
right dude you know I mean you realize
what that is to get to that level of an
F-16 fighter pilot that you're part of
the Thunderbirds and stuff like that and
this guy is flying at
Southwest you know what he should be
armed you know what he's he's not going
to hurt anybody that doesn't need to be
hurt you know you know the everybody
that steps on that plane deserves
protection from one idiot that wants to
create an incident and you know what
sometimes it takes a guy you know that's
in there that is armed and if that's
what it takes to arm a pilot arm a
teacher that is a solid person in their
job do it when you became a police
officer in your heart did you you really
think you'd make a
difference I always I always kind of
laughed at people said you know I I'm
here to make a difference and yeah you
know I just want to help people I want
to make a difference and it's like you
know for the most part when people are
contacted by police officers it's a bad
day I don't care what it is either
somebody did something to you that
you're calling the police and so
something bad has happened or the police
are coming and they're knocking on your
door and now they're taking control and
custody of you it's a bad day you know
police officers are there to keep the
peace they're there to make sure that
crimes don't occur they're there if a
crime does occur let's try to find the
person that created that crime that's a
problem that is a problem for other
people in our community so we can
separate them from it and hopefully have
the community be safe you know from that
person that's what we're there for but
you're never going to be that person
that that people want to see because
it's always a bad day that they're
seeing you
it's you know I it's just the way it is
you know every now and then we get to
you know I I would go at Christmas time
I would go out and I'd have a bunch of
stuffed toys and I would stop my kids
and I would you know let them come to my
trunk and take you know a stuffed toy or
something like that that's a nice
contact but that's just not the reality
of what being a police officer
is that's uh I know if I became a cop
it'd be to to help you know just to
really do the little things little
things that I don't see people doing
anymore or cops doing anymore I don't
see that interaction with cops
especially in Los Angeles yeah I don't
see a lot of inter I know no cops you
know now there's another ref but the
pony isn't the guy a sheriff Mike
Beltran he's LA County Sheriff a sheriff
and he's narcotics and all that stuff
some right right I had conversation for
them how did now before you became a cop
you got involved with jiu-jitsu no I got
involved with jiu-jitsu when I was a
police officer I was
um oh let's see I want to say back in
one 91 or so I had a friend that I did
he did Judo and I used to wrestle and I
boxed and we would work out and you know
when it came to you know throw he
couldn't throw me off of things but if
he put the ghee on me he could throw me
and and he was the one that you know
told me about this family from Brazil he
goes there's these guys they're from
Brazil he goes they like to fight on the
ground you would love them he goes I
can't think of they're down in the South
Bay he said they're out of a garage and
so I was like yeah okay and then I you
know just through I'd gone to do a lot
of different martial arts and stuff my
dad growing up hated martial arts my Dad
loved boxing and loved amateur wrestling
professional wrestling he would not let
me walk I'd sneak it because he would
never let me watch it because that's
fake that's bull you know my dad was all
into what was he thought was real and
what you know really worked in a
fighting situation was big to him that
his son did wrestling and boxing and so
that's what I grew up with and then when
I uh I ended up meeting hor and Gracie
and I fell in love with
jiu-jitsu the first guy that I ever
rolled with was Hoy you know that was my
my first go and they said well what do
you want to I said whatever you want to
do you know and he said well let's just
roll first you know and I was on top and
I have him in a cradle you know and I
was like
290 Pounds at the time and he was you
know 180 pounds
and I was like the guys I'm thinking
myself this guy's nothing you know and
he's sitting here and he's breathing and
I'm putting on I'm creating a lot of
pressure and I'm squeezing I'm you know
driving my weight into him and he's
wiggling his leg and he's moving and
moving and moving and he I end up taking
my arm trying to move it out and he you
know tells him he says he gives me this
line and he says and he's breathing
like and he goes oh my friend you see
movie
Rocky right and I kind of like rela I'm
like is he talking to me right he says
everyone think he lose too and within
about a minute he's got me in an arm bar
and you know I tap out of it because
they told me you know if if something's
AR hurt tap out you know okay and I L
looked at how'd you do that because I
didn't know how he did it you know I
knew that he swung his body around but I
was like I was thinking I was going to
take his back and he swinging all my arm
was going straight and I was like how
did you do that and I fell in love with
it and from that moment I started
going and I started going just because
it was something new and it was this
whole element of joint manipulations
that I had never been experienced to
some of the wrestling you know it
intertwined with it but theirs was
totally different because wrestling when
you know I was taught to wrestle it was
a grind it was about how hard I could
drive into you how much I could crush
you how much I could run you and make
things hard it was what we called the
grind and everything that they did was
about oh my friend you work too hard oh
my friend take it easy relax you know
and that was the part I was I had a hard
time with because that was they kept on
saying you you relax you're going too
hard you know that's the only thing I
knew how to do at the time and and I
just was intrigued by it and I stayed
with it I just loved it and you still go
no no no I mean you know you got you got
the black belt though you teach and
everything still to the academy
eventually I got a black belt but that's
just you know I think they're more out
of like it's kind of like the actor that
never won anything and they say yeah you
acted here here's a reward for Lifetime
Achievement and so you know I look at it
it's I could roll you know I I know what
I'm doing I know how to teach someone I
loved you just I got to a point I didn't
care about the black belt I really
didn't and I looked at it was my ideas
were it's not about the belt it's about
because you know and and the reason I
was saying that you I was you know with
guys and I was at at that time you know
even early UFC's I was rolling I was
rolling with all the fighters and you
know Mark Coleman i' roll with Mark
Coleman that dude was so freaking strong
and such a beast he didn't have a belt
well he's an Olympic level wrestler but
he got no belt so it's like at a certain
point I was like I don't care about the
belt it's about how well you do it's
about what you know it's about how well
you can do it it's about how well you
can make somebody else do it and that's
you know eventually you know I got the
belt and that's nice but then it's just
a giant Target on your back and everyone
wants to tap you out so if you put on a
ghe and you you and you go on the thing
it's like everyone's like I want to roll
with you okay and it's like here let's
go right and they're they're going go
hard I said no go here we go I do that I
tap real quick right and they go what
are you doing I said well you want I
know you wanted to tap me so there it
was so now let's roll right and so it's
like I have a good time with it I love
the sport I love jiujitsu because it
changed my life it really did and it
calmed me
down the one thing that it really did is
is it changed who I was as far as you
know importance of I for years I was
that guy that you know I walked around
and I'm a I'm a nice person I like
everybody but if you gave me that look I
would be the first one to to look back
and I'm I'm going to start to Target you
because that was who I was and the
Jiu-Jitsu changed me it was like who
cares yeah you can beat me whatever you
know but it really changed who I was it
calmed me down it made me
a lot better person it's doing that for
me I'm terrible I don't have a belt and
I don't want a belt I just go to breathe
I just go to breathe and I'm I'm all
about people wanting to achieve and if
that belt is what you think is your
achievement point that you want awesome
do it let's go from white to Blue to
purple to Brown to Black I don't care
that's great you know there's just
certain people you know BJ got his black
belt in four years I have a girl you
know that's been with me at my gym you
know forever fle oh she got hers in four
years three and a half years got hers
even faster than BJ and she was
phenomenal and was a phenomenal
competitor and you know just did an
incredible
job but it's not
about that it's not about getting to
that point it's about the journey that's
what's important and it's what you learn
during that journey and the amount of
time and effort that you put into that
journey and the the routes that it takes
you and the people that you meet and the
things that occur that's what the life
of being a martial artist and studying
whatever it is whether it's Jiu-Jitsu or
Judo or you know kmo or whatever it is
you like that's why you do it it's not
to be the guy that you know can go out
and beat up anybody or look at there's
always going to be like I said before
there's always somebody out there that's
going to whip your ass that is just the
way it is and if you think that that's
going to be what's going to cover your
butt you know black belt great you know
I think Hoy said it best black belt
covers about two inches of your ass and
there's a whole lot exposed so you know
you need to understand that it's
about
experiencing a system and a lifestyle
that calms you centers you makes you
just a better person that's what I think
it's about well it enhanced my comedy
It's Made Me way better as a comic I see
something how did it do that you got to
tell me on that
that's to me when I first rolled on to
jiu-jitsu was 49 years old I'm still
overweight when I first did a hip Escape
I thought my [__] I thought I was
going to die when I was first told to do
that first hip Escape down that role I
thought I was going to die I had never
established and I played tackle football
I played high school basketball I did it
all I thought that that was just amazing
I thought I was going to die I the first
three times I went to Jiu-Jitsu I
thought I was going to die I really did
there were Parts where I was like I
can't believe I'm doing this this is
ridic ridiculous I got to take aspirins
and write a will if I keep coming to
this [__] because I'm going to [__]
die but uh I liked it so much like and I
was so bad at it and it brought me back
to Comedy when you first get into comedy
after about year you're stuck and you're
like I want I can't wait to perform at
the punchline I can't wait but you can't
you can't there's no you're not ready
you're frustrated and that's what I am
now it frustrates me this times I'm like
[__] it I'm not going to go cuz I'm
never going to get better but it's like
I got to go to get
better when I walk outside Jiu-Jitsu and
I say this in front of Mrs Mack I got
the biggest dick in the world when I
finish an hour and a half class me for
me feel good about yourself it's it's so
[__] hard for me when they grab me
and I'm on the bottom and a guy's bead
Falls in my eye and his sweats burning
in my [__] eye and I can't breathe
and I don't know and that it to me is
where you want to be put every day
because everything else seems easy
nothing you traffic on the 405 [__] I
had a 200 lb guy going from my [__]
neck for an hour and a half I got to
look straight ahead for three weeks I
can't even look you know uh these little
things when I walk out of Jiu-Jitsu you
can't stop me that hour that's that's
better than cocaine it's better than sex
it's better than anything I ever CU I
know how hard it is for me I know how
hard it is for me I see 20 year olds
[__] dying drenched sweating so I
know a 52y old doing it that's 100
pounds overweight and that's never done
it if I would have wrestled in high
school and two years of college okay I
would have had some Basics I know you
know I get somebody with neon belly I go
for a [__] ride you know hegan loves
neon belly neon B how many times I've
landed on my [__] head a load too oh
my God but I'll go back and I said it on
the Rogan podcast that this to me uh I
know I suck now I'm horrible at [__]
Jiu-Jitsu oh doesn't matter but it
doesn't matter to me because because I
know I'm going to get better just like
it makes me doing the comedy for all
those years taught me that I could do
this it's just going to click one day it
might take three years it might take six
years it might take eight years but one
day it's all going to come together the
movements the the the [__] sweeps I'm
going to get it now you get on top of me
it takes me 20 minutes to think about by
the time the Bell goes off I still
didn't what was I supposed to do [__]
know let me give some shout outs real
quick and oh [__] Lisi at how you
feeling good good Budd it's a beautiful
day to be alive you're with the Jews I
want to get remind me of something I got
to tell you about this thing I watched
the other day this documentary because
it had to do a lot with the police sha
Jones I love you [__] Paul Lynch
Renee an Carion the Puerto Ricans Lista
Thomas Paul crester 2323 Philip Fletcher
Don Wrangler and Eric costada I love you
[__] have a great week anybody
see a documentary robbed no oh [__]
what's it about it's about Jim it's
about Norton Ken Norton and Muhammad Ali
the third fight third fight at Bronx in
the Bronx that was that was a Yankee
Stadium Yankee Stadium horrible oh my
God dorton one dude I remember watching
that fight and I was
like I couldn't believe they gave it to
Ali Ali could not handle Norton style oh
my God Norton was hitting him yep if you
think Lavar Johnson hits [__] hard oh
my God Norton was big athletic and his
technique that overhand right he was
throwing was [__] brutal you could
hear it just every time he hit his arms
or something you could just hear it but
it wasn't what was going on in the
stadium that's what this documentary is
about it was about what's going on
outside the stadium with the New York
Police Department how they couldn't
handle
it oh you got to see this [__] I watch
it so what happened was all these people
you know to to get a ticket to go see a
boxing match you know 1970 it was still
50 bucks 50 bucks is a lot of money 100
bucks was like a th000 now you know so
all these people came up from the
suburbs and they basically they just
went up there to get
robbed and they were so many people
getting robbed it was the time with the
Warriors all those gangs in New York so
all these gangs were there robbing
people and there's a part where uh the
the the newscaster the guy goes I
remember being outside and people
getting taking down and yelling for the
police but the police were so
overwhelmed they were just turning their
backs to people a see oh my God I
couldn't do that no me neither I don't
know what how the One Cop goes there was
a point where there was 75 people and I
was there by myself cops were all over
running breaking up fights people T
taking cars he goes it was just one of
the worst nights ever in New York but it
wasn't about the fight it was about all
these people that had just been
humiliated robbed just they they took
that jewelry they cash on the way out
because the cops hadn't planned for it
like they had never really Bob arum was
the promoter Bob arum was crying and
he's like I felt terrible he goes first
I got this Ken Norton crying Ken Norton
was [__] crying he's a man a grown
man bigger than lavard Johnson I keep
saying lavard Johnson is that his name
yeah lavard Johnson he's not in the UFC
no more no he's a Bellator Bellator now
he [__] H this guy but him uh good
guy really he got shot he's a conf boy
he got shot he's a comp family at a
family family
party it was at a family party I think
it was in Fresno oh wasn't here he's not
from down here no he's from uh Fresno
area and he was up uh just at a party
and people drove by and words exchange
and he got shot you were also here for
the hey day of gangs you really think
about absolutely now when I did time in
Colorado I did time with a [__] really
really and I know you're looking at me
crazy really good guy
really good guy I mean I really like
this kid he was just a young kid he had
grown up in Compton that's all he knew
drugs you know what look at all he knew
absolutely you know what what people
don't understand is and I would get kids
it's they're stuck because they're going
to school they don't want to be part of
a gang and every day at school they're
getting they're getting brutalized
they're getting beat up they're getting
their stuff taken and they're getting it
done by gang members and there's one way
to keep it from happening either be part
of that gang or part of the gang that is
going to protect you from and eventually
they just succumb to it and say I I need
help and those people are to them their
family at the time and they start to do
it and then things occur out of it they
start making bad decisions because they
have to you know if you want to be part
of the game you're going to have to do
certain things and you're going to sell
drugs and you're going to Rob and you're
going to do some things that are not
good and you know I had there's all
kinds of people you know that I ran into
and not all of them are bad they may be
a gang member but they're not all bad
they just make poor decisions and those
poor decisions affect their lives and
sometimes for the rest of their life you
were here for colors also right oh yeah
oh [__] yeah colors that was when I was
I was working gangs when colors came out
all my friends are in that stupid movie
now the guy that they base that off of
did they base it off a certain cop or
something like that no they base it off
a South Bureau crash which was crash was
you know our acronym for our ganging it
was Community Resources against Street
hoodlums what a everything in LPD had
been some stupid acronym but that was
what the crash was and uh they uh sha
Penn became friends with a friend of
mine named Dennis Fanning he did the
show yeah he did the podcast he did the
podcast yeah that's how I met him I met
him and he uh you know he became friends
with Dennis and Dennis was part of South
Bureau crash at the time and to start
talking to him and then took him on a
ride along and that's how the whole
thing really started and he became and
he was you know the main star of the
show and stuff but all there's a lot of
guys Dennis is in the movie he's he's in
there a couple of times and stuff so I
make fun of him he's from Chicago
originally just a tough you know
thickheaded Irishman just like you know
other guys I know but uh you know Dennis
was a just a great guy and Penn just
fell in love with him as far as what he
did as a police officer out the streets
you know you take you know I I took
quite a few star stars out on Ride Along
we would call them they would go out
actually you know see us work and there
was ones that were hysterical you know I
can't remember the one guy's name he was
in uh there was the movie with Richard
Gear where he was a uh I want to say
Internal Affairs Internal Affairs yeah
he was the he was the the husband of the
wife that Richard was doing and he came
out and and I scared him to death Andy
Garcia no it wasn't it was the other guy
cassavetes is his name last name I can't
think of his first name Nick yeah I want
to say Nick cavetti and and he was you
know he went out and ride along with me
and watching what we're doing and we got
into a little Pursuit and and he say he
goes that's it you got to take me back I
can't take this I'm going to have a
heart attack out here you know and it
was you know you drive fast you
sometimes it's scary sometimes it's F
but the the adrenaline rush is what
makes you go back it's it's you have
scary days joh oh sure absolutely anyone
shot at
absolutely no [__] oh yeah no one hit me
though so I'm
good you see people's reaction when the
gun goes off is it [__] crazy when
the cop isn't prepared for that you know
what you need to always you know you
always need to be in a position where
you don't get surprised by a lot and
there's times when it can happen because
you can get into what we call Ambush
situations and you can drive into
something and it can it can shock you
but you know to sit there and say you
know don't be afraid that's stupid you
know there's certain emotions that we
all have and you know I talk about fear
all the time and I don't care if it's
fear of a situation ation a person
whatever it's going to be fear is a
normal thing you know it's a good thing
it helps you it makes you aware it tells
you something's wrong here there are
other emotions that are out there like
Panic that's a stupid emotion if you
panic you're you're you're relying on an
emotion that's going to do absolutely
nothing for you it's going to only lead
you into into a worse situation so you
know people talk about being courageous
and heroes and all that stuff you know
to me a courageous person you know
there's no courageous people that didn't
have fear
because if you weren't afraid there's
nothing to be courageous about so it's
you know you go and you do certain
situations and you you you walk out of
it and it's one of the reasons where a
lot of people sit there and they they'll
talk about OH police officers make you
know fun of things they joke you have to
you know because things occur and you
got to laugh about them or you got to
make jokes about them because you see
things you know there there's a certain
again element of society that you know
does things to to other people that you
end up having to see the end results of
it and it's a nasty world at times and
you know the average person will never
see those things and you know sometimes
you got to make jokes because it's your
only way of dealing with it because it's
no different than being in you know uh
military personnel and going down down
range and seeing things you know the
average person has no idea what those
military personnel people are doing what
they're seeing you know to have a friend
that you're talking to in the next thing
is you know there's an explosion going
off and you see pieces of them you know
and they're screaming out those are
things that you you just don't forget
you just it doesn't leave your mind it's
not oh we move on to the next day they
stay with you forever and there's
certain things as a police officer
they're going to stay with you forever
things that you see things that you do
some you're proud of some you're not
that's just that's just part of the job
so what makes you go back then like if
you see like your friend blown up or
someone shoots at you if that were me
I'd be applying for C dealersh or
anything like that's okay but you know
what and again look it's no different
than look at there there is like I said
there's a rush and everyone everybody's
different you know there's there's
people that are out there that you know
I love excitement I like doing what
other people think are scary it's not
scary to
me you know Fighters you look at people
you know people look at Fighters and
they go oh my God you know I couldn't
imagine you know knowing I was going to
get in a fight and because they look at
it in their own world and they're scared
to death of a physical confrontation
with another human being because they
know they've kind of had it happen
they've had that feeling that Rush of
adrenaline has gone through them and all
of a sudden they're shaking and they
can't stop it and they go why would
anyone want that and they think that's
what the fighter gets you know and
that's not what a professional fighter
gets the F the fighter is doing things
different but the fighter gets a drug
and this is why a lot of them can't stop
is when you walk out into an arena
that's got 17 20,000 people and all of a
sudden the lights go down and this music
comes on that's your music and you're
bouncing and all a sudden you're coming
out and everyone's wanting to touch you
everyone's screaming your name
everything is going off it is a drug
that you can get nowhere else and you
can't bottle it you can't smoke it it is
a drug that only only
they understand and when they stop doing
it the drug goes away and that's why you
see a lot of them going back well it's
the same thing with sometimes with
police work depending upon what kind of
officer you are and what you're doing
98% of it is boredom but the 2% that if
you're if you're a hardworking cop and
you're getting into things that 2%
that's a drug and if you're that guy
that likes that drug you always want to
go back to it you know putting away
somebody for me would be a great day
saving somebody's life a cat out of a
[__] tree you know uh talking to a
kid that got bullied that those would be
the things that would make my day as a
cop but that's good that's good that's
making a kid feel good and you know and
again you know it's like everyone looks
at you know bullying
it's God damn I mean everybody I don't
care who everybody has been bullied if
they say no they're lying I was bullied
I bullied people I'm sure you know
there's people I actually went to a high
school 30-year High School reunion so I
could tell a guy hey I just want to tell
you I'm sorry I was a turd you know and
he didn't show up and then I see him I
actually see him in a fight he comes up
and he says John right and I tell him I
said dude I just want to tell you man
I'm sorry for the way I treated you he
goes you were awesome to me right and
I'm like no I was a [__] and he goes
I don't remember that glad you don't
remember it cuz I do I was a tur but you
know everyone is bull because that's
it's part of human nature if you know
kids you know you watch them and they
start if they can start to dominate
something they do it's what happens and
it's to sit there and tell you know
people oh we we've we've got this new
problem it's not a new problem it's been
going on for centuries the only thing I
would say is and because I went through
it and I'm the biggest I'm not
anti-technology anti internet at all I
love I'm the biggest nerd in the world
but if I had to go through some of the
stuff I went through and
wasn't able to go home and get away from
it if like I was going online and and
seeing it more and more at night I can
see why people get upset and I the kids
killing themselves is a lot more drastic
than I would ever think I wouldn't do
but if it's non-stop all weekend all
night I can see where that where that
online you mean yeah like Facebook and
instant messaging and but that's why
there karate and but you know and that
there you go see and this is what for
that kid that you're talking about
you're right it seems like it's
everything right it's their world their
world is falling apart and they have no
idea how to stop it and it's you know
the one thing I love out of my gym is
you know the kid program and all the
kids that I have had you know I've been
open now for eight nine years and some
of these kids I've had since they were
you know four years old five years old
and now they're you know they're young
men they don't have problems now you
know part of it is we tell them if I
ever find out you are doing things to
other people just cuz you can I'm gonna
fall on you I'm just telling you
straight out your job is to protect
those people your job is to be the guy
that tells everyone hey let him be and
put your arm around say it's okay don't
worry about him I don't I'm always hey
I'll be your friend that's your job but
the kids that I have they have such
confidence because they know they know
that if someone does do something
they're not alone they they know that
they can do something now I'm not
they're not supposed to go out and and
do it but I have I have one I have
there's a kid who's been in my gym
forever he just as a freshman in high
school I was lucky enough to get
wrestling going in the Santa Clarita
Valley where I live for a long time it's
where my Gym's at because for 38 39
years it was no wrestling in that Valley
great football everything no wrestling
it took me forever to get wrestling back
in that Valley this is the first year
they have had an actual one high school
Valencia High has a wrestling team for
the first year they came in second in
their uh in the the freelance League
which is everybody together which
allowed them to put four kids to
CIF and one of the kids as a freshman
just took second he got beat by a senior
who was ranked second in the state in
the last minute of the third round and
this a freshman now this kid is
phenomenal and everything he has learned
he's learned at my place but he is
confident in everything he does he's got
a sister that is gorgeous and she's
being bullied and she can her parents
brought her into me for me to sit down
and talk to her and talk to her about
look at this is what you need to do this
is what you and and I brought up her
brother I said I said tell me how many
people you know I said your brother's
younger how many people are picking on
chance she goes nobody they're all
afraid of him I go why cuz he picks on
him she goes no they just know I go he
has confidence I want you to have
confidence too because the more
confident you are as far as who you are
as a person doesn't mean you have to be
confident that you can beat people up
but the more confident about who you are
as a person and what you stand for the
better off you're going to be in
everything you
do that's why the J Jitsu was helping me
with that's exactly it that's why that's
it let me give a shout out to sponsors
we'll get you out of here John John that
was you know listen man I'll get you
back here again and we'll talk MMA
[__] but for right now I want it was
nice not talking no that's what I
figured I figured you talk about MMA
every [__] day of the week Jiu-Jitsu
let's talk about the police thing it was
very interesting to me and I when I saw
that I thought you were a cop from 91 on
I could because I was just telling Lee
when OJ killed his wife I was living in
Boulder and I was going through a
divorce and I wanted to kill that [__]
so I was watching this whole OJ thing
very [__] closely to see how I was
going to get away with my [__] murder
see if I was going to use a Bronco or
maybe a blazer that to me uh you know
I've read all those books I wanted to be
before I got my felony John I wanted to
be a lawyer I I I got in in uh I got
into the University of Colorado and as a
Latin they would have going to let me
into a law school I would have had to
take a test and then I got the felony
and I got in trouble so I read all those
things I read uh the the Tupac book out
of rampart I I read all the OJ
information I could I watch Law and
Order that's my favorite [__] show of
all time you know uh when I when my
mother died I grew I moved in with a
family and and the middle child was a
cop I I hung out with the younger guy
but the middle guy sold pot when we were
kids and I was always tight with him and
one day he became a cop he cleaned up
his life and became a cop and he had the
12th AG shift and he would tell me I get
bored out there you want to ride around
and I would he would pick me up at 12 I
was a sophomore in high school I'd go
buy a six-pack of Coors Light and I just
sit in his car at night drinking the
beers he'd be with the speed gun seeing
the cars go by and he go 80 what do you
think
n 78 what do you think nah and then he
would if he got a bad call he was he
would drop me off and he would go do it
but uh I've always had even though I had
trouble growing up I always had a
certain respect for cops and I like
hearing about it I want to see your side
of the [__] fence you know I mean uh
it's funny you said that about when we
get pulled over we think I robbed the
jewelry store one time okay before we
robbed the jewelry store the jewelry was
going to go in the trunk but when we
robbed the jewelry store the trunk
wouldn't [__] open wouldn't [__]
open now we got this thing of jewelry
the people going run back call the
police ah and we throw the jewelry in
the in the in the uh back seat my friend
sit in the one guy sits here one guy
sits here I sit in the back seat I can't
even see my feet it's covered with all
the jewelry we're pulling away we hear
the sirens coming we pull up to a red
light and we see a cop coming at us and
he stops with the red light even though
his things are on because he's got
things and all of a sudden you hear and
the trunk just opened up by itself right
in front of the cop I'm like they're
going to [__] pull us over now the
guy just went right through we didn't
get away with it we got picked up weeks
later one night I was driving around
with a friend of mine and we were
[__] tanked and we had a spackle
bucket we were 18 we had a spackle
bucket and we were drinking he wasn't
drinking but I was drinking with my
buddies in the car he was like a he had
a hepatitis or some [__] so he couldn't
drink so we were snorting coke and
getting [__] up it was 5: in the
morning cop pulled us over he's looking
in the back seat I mean I thought we
were going to I would have just been
getting out of jail now and all of a
sudden he got a call and he goes just
drive [__] slower next time and they
took off and we
like so you never know sometimes you do
I mean I don't know how many times I see
lights and just from my normal me being
me claiming responsibility I go that
guy's to pull me over because he
probably saw me looking at my phone
three blocks down I have a panic attack
whenever there's sir in a song like in a
song like a lot of rap songs now have
sirens in it and I freak out on like
when I'm driving late oh it's
terrifying when you hear a siren in the
song you don't know it's supposed to be
in there and you're looking around it's
[__] loud I want to give a shout out
to my main people over at hit.com
optimizing [__] with their
ready minerals and all the stuff they
got to make you better like like I've
said a thousand times man if you go to a
Chinese restaurant and the pork fried
rice sucks everything else is going to
suck right or wrong on it the Alpha
Brain is their trademark it's the whole
show it's the whole cabang it's got 100
100% money back guarantee and we don't
even want the [__] pills back so if
it don't help you 100% guarantee and
take it from there if as far as minerals
are concerned I'll get you 10% off the
weights the battle ropes you're on your
[__] own go to hit.com in the Box
what you press leave church church
[__] ch youch and get 10% off they
also have the stay on it program it gets
delivered right to your house is Joe
giving you any of that stuff yet no n
somebody just called me the other day
and said you got to talk to Joe to give
me some mushroom Tech those [__]
mushrooms make me go crazy when I'm
rolling he's 50 and the guy goes I roll
for three hours on those [__]
quadricep mushrooms they call shroom
Tech Sport and he has sport or immune
and the sport supposedly man [__]
people go crazy on those things like
they just roll for hours uh Iron Dragon
TV classic martial art films Yip Man
what's the other guy Jackie Chan Jackie
Chan ta hero taii hero they just keep
adding on titles 4K technology Iron
Dragon TV has got it going on if you
look into classic martial art films go
to Iron Dragon TV if you mention my name
what they put in the Box Joey Joey Jo OE
y you get two free movies for free these
guys got 30 years of Martial artart
films there this martial art thing
started in 1968 and these guys got all
the films Mafia films one-armed
swordsman [__] like that go to Iron
Dragon tv.com today again you thinking
of quitting smoking e hit cigarettes hit
e cigarett hit ecigarettes what the [__]
what is it hit e hits.com right now they
got the cigar I don't know where the
hell it is I got to bring some more from
the house and they got the little e pens
you could smoke ecigarettes you could
smoke from 24 milligrams down to zero if
you're thinking of qu go to hys sig.com
and press in Joey's Church oh [__] and
get 20% off your first order
also nailedit life.com they ain't
[__] around with their wax go to
nailedit life.com at oil and wax go to
the page and see what they got to offer
you also on the vapor pen you get 20%
off and that's how we do it put in Joey
Diaz that's right J OE y d a z don't
forget I'm at crackers Thursday the
following week I'm in hilarious in
Cleveland and the following week I'm in
Sacramento but let's just worry about
[__] Indianapolis this weekend bring
your snorkel [__] it's going deep
where are you this weekend get this next
weekend I gotta go to Connecticut for a
Bellator on Friday and then I gota get
my ass back here for the UFC on Saturday
so you're doing Saturday you're doing L
Fair Friday and Saturday as they're
doing it they calling it l Fair L
Fair that's the guys MMA junk G calling
it that's it my brother that's it all
right Big John hey who loves you more
than me thank you very much man for
doing this for me on Pleasure brother
I've been dying to get you on and uh I'm
happy came down very interesting police
stories I love all these it's very cool
cuz it's a it's a big hot button issue
right now and a lot of people have a lot
of negative things to say and a lot of
it's warranted when you see some of the
videos a lot the is but it's you don't
get to hear the other point of view if
you've known me on the show I always
talk about something and I've never
brought it up because before I could
judge it I got to be in that [__] car
I don't know what would happen in St
Louis I know kind of what happened in
Staten Island with the guy that choked
him I didn't like that one right I
didn't like that one in St Louis I don't
know what happened and it's like
anything you know it's their word
against mine mine against theirs who the
[__] knows right uh half the people that
know Michael Brown they're out there
looting again you know it's an excuse to
do it's it's you know what's the old
saying adage that our moms just say two
wrongs don't make a right that's true
and that's what these things add up to
be at least that's what I see but anyway
who gives a [__] what I see Big John Mrs
Mack I love you looking good with the
new hair look at you you're a
savage or not new hair but you let it
grow out it looks [__] Sensational
and you smell smell good too Lis at
don't forget it snowed in [__] Israel
did it really yeah in Jerusalem yeah oh
in Jerusalem wow that's like in the
middle right by the [__] cross right
there what you what what's that almost
almost when are you what do you got
today today I got nothing I got a a Blog
coming out tomorrow okay so thank thank
you I got a lot of nice emails about the
blog and the podcast so thank you who
takes care of you like me don't don't
don't I [__] tell you this [__] I
love you guys see you Tuesday at 3: we
got a gang member Tuesday at 3 there you
so we're going to balance this
[__] out this week all right
stay black have a great week start your
Monday off on the right foot stay black
people
bye go to on it.com and use cobor Church
to get 10% off of all their optimization
products like Alpha brand new mood sh
tech commun shro tech sport go to
hits.com
and uh better tasting longer lasting
proof is in the Vape use Cobra Joey's
Church to get 20% off go to irondragon
tv.com and use called where Joey get
free rentals and go
to uh nail life.com use C- Joey Diaz to
get 20% off the premier Vapor pin on the
market